here's a question most people get wrong  suppose a stock decreases 50 percent in  year one and increases by 50 percent in  year two the stock does not pay any  dividends is the Stock's final value  more than equal to or less than its  initial value most people think the  answer is equal to because they think  the loss and the gain will cancel out  but this is not true if you start out  with a hundred dollars then a fifty  percent loss will leave you with fifty  dollars then a fifty percent gain will  only return you to a final value of  seventy five dollars and that is less  than the initial value the timing  actually doesn't matter if you have the  gain then the loss you would still end  up less than the initial value it's  important to know that you need a larger  percentage gain to recover from a  percentage loss this is an important  lesson to know because you always want  to get the numbers right when it comes  to your money